as a character he's got massive teeth
into the Rings huge he bites beat his
head so if he's like those eyes going on
I just enjoy looking at it to be fair no
in theaters this weekend venom and a
star is born what will you see this is
your weekend ticket
[Music]
Tom Hardy and another comic book action
movie yes please
venom hits the big screen this weekend
technically it's a Marvel movie but a
Sony Marvel movie so not exactly a part
of the Marvel Universe but kind of and
probably will crossover maybe but also
maybe not we don't know this movie stars
the gorgeous Tom Hardy who technically
plays journalist Eddie Brock not venom
venom is the daily life form that takes
over Eddie's body giving him superpowers
technically it's the symbian who takes
over Eddie's body making them both venom
that's why they say but separately its
Eddie Brock the symbiote and venom is
when they come together so I mean it's
not it's not venom before I have a
parasite this movie is for you if you're
a fan of action comic book movies you
can't hardly wait for Tom Hardy or
you're a fan of movies based in biology
and life science I remember we're hardly
texting me black eyes the song that
starts the movie you know in the middle
of the night he's like I wrote this last
night what do you think of it it was so
exciting for me to watch him become a
musician you can pick your nose and you
can pick your friends but you can't pick
your friends nose think about it
a star is born comes out this weekend
starring Lady gaga and Bradley Cooper
and also directed by Bradley Cooper what
this iteration is actually the thirdly
make of the 1937 musical romantic comedy
of the same name Jackson Maine played by
Bradley is like a super good and
well-known musician who discovered and
also falls in love with a just as good
but not known at all musician Ali played
by Lady gaga fun fact parts of this
movie were filmed at the Coachella Music
Festival in 2017 this movie is for you
if you enjoy musical romantic comedies
you love Bradley Cooper and are curious
to see how he does as a director or you
like Lady Gaga and wanna see Bradley
Cooper poker face that is your weekend
ticket what's your pick and check back
next week for a little Ryan Gosling
action in first man
[Music]